[Musique]
chers habitants de la vienne la période
difficile que nous subissons depuis
plusieurs mois ne nous permet pas de
nous retrouver en grand nombre à
l'occasion des voeux nous le regrettons
mais devons être responsable et
exemplaire
je souhaitais néanmoins avec l'assemblée
départementale qui m'entourent
aujourd'hui pouvoir m'adresser à vous
pour vous témoigner
à l'occasion de cette nouvelle année
trois messages positifs un message de
confiance un message de solidarité un
message de remerciement 2020 aura marqué
profondément les esprits tant elle a été
une année hors norme une année de
fatigue de colère de solitude de
souffrance mais 2020 aura aussi prouvé
combien nous sommes en capacité de nous
adapter d'être solidaire et créatif face
à l'adversité retrouvons la confiance la
confiance en nos institutions la
confiance en nos collectivités qui met
tout en oeuvre pour faire face à cette
crise sans précédent la confiance les
uns envers les autres
notre département a toutes les capacités
et toute la volonté pour se réinventer
et voir l'avenir avec ambition
avec mes collègues de l'assemblée
départementale
nous avons adopté récemment un budget de
confiance pour l'année qui est à l'image
de ce que la vienne a toujours été une
terre d'ambition et de projets nous
assumons plus que jamais nos compétences
au premier rang desquels la solidarité
pour soutenir et accompagner les plus
fragiles nous serons au rendez-vous dans
tous les domaines qui nous concerne et
notamment la protection de l'enfance et
des familles le soutien aux
bénéficiaires du rsa qu'il nous faut
accompagner vers le retour à l'emploi
l'aide envers les personnes en situation
de handicap la protection de nos aînés
nous assumons par ailleurs une politique
ambitieuse d'investissements qui va se
poursuivre sur tout le territoire
le numérique notamment avec la fibre
partout pour tous nous défendons
l'obtention du label territoire 100%
numérique qui nous permettra de
bénéficier de financements importants
pour accompagner l'éducation de nos
jeunes notre département est plus que
jamais tourné vers l'avenir
il est le partenaire privilégié des
territoires dans bien des domaines
notamment avec le dispositif des aides
aux projets des communes nous engagerons
les mesures ambitieuses qui permettront
à notre département de réussir
l'éducation
le schéma routier celui de l'habitat le
plan environnemental cese la culture le
tourisme le sport en 2021 il faut aller
de l'avant
investir anticiper l'avenir nous avons
entre nos mains la relance de notre
territoire et nous assumons cette
politique d'investissement qui permet le
développement
nous accompagnerons le futuroscope avec
lequel nous lançons un grand plan de
développement pour donner un nouveau
souffle au parc et à notre département
nous serons aussi
comme depuis toujours aux côtés des
acteurs touristiques pour lesquelles
nous avons adopté récemment un nouveau
plan de relance
ces investissements sont l'indispensable
moteur de l'attractivité de la vienne
l'attractivité qui se concrétise
clairement par les derniers chiffres de
l'insee
la vienne est au 4e rang des
départements de nouvelles aquitaine pour
la progression annuelle de sa population
le premier or littoral atlantique le
seul avec la gironde a affiché un solde
positif
la preuve par l'exemple que
l'investissement attire les forces vives
sans investissement pas d'avenir
pas d'emploi je veux enfin profiter de
ce moment pour remercier en mon nom et
celui de la collectivité
celles et ceux qui assument leur mission
au service des habitants de la vienne
nos soignants nos personnels du secteur
sanitaire et social et toutes celles et
tous ceux qui oeuvrent de près ou de
loin et nous permettent de continuer de
vivre pendant les périodes de
confinement
nous sommes avec mes collègues présents
sur le terrain aux côtés de toutes les
forces vives de la vienne et de tous les
habitants particulièrement les plus
fragiles
battons nous ayons confiance soyons
solidaires 2021 devra être une année de
solidarité humaine territoriale
professionnelles familiales
tous les élus autour de moi sont
mobilisés c'est ensemble que nous
réussirons
je vous adresse mes voeux les plus
chaleureux pour cette nouvelle année
[Musique]
ensemble pour l'éducation
ensemble ou l'aménagement du territoire
et l'aéroport ensemble pour la jeunesse
et le sport
ensemble pour l'insertion les le retour
à l'emploi
ensemble pour la culture et
l'événementiel ensemble pour les routes
[Musique]
ensemble pour les personnes âgées et les
personnes handicapées ensemble pour
l'action sociale l'enfance et la famille
ensemble pour la santé
[Musique]
ensemble pour la coopération
internationale
ensemble pour l'agriculture
ensemble pour les ménages non immigrés
ensemble pour l'économie touristique
ensemble pour le logement et
l'environnement
ensemble pour un budget maîtrisé
[Musique]